-Wow.
Thank you guys so much.
I'm so excited
to be in New York City.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is amazing.
So great to be here.
I actually just got back
from my high school reunion.
[ Light laughter ]
Yeah, they asked if
I wanted to perform at it.
I was like, "I would rather
strip at my family reunion...
[ Laughter ]
...than tell jokes
to the girl who, during class,
pierced her own belly button
with a stapler."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, grew up in
a real meth-y area.
[ Light laughter ]
My high school crush showed up
with a marijuana leaf
tattooed on his face.
[ Light laughter ]
I was still in denial.
I was like, "Well, someone's
not afraid of commitment."
[ Laughter and applause ]
I come from some weird DNA.
My parents met playing
in a professional
foosball tournament.
[ Laughter ]
So if you're embarrassed you met
your spouse on Tinder,
could be worse.
[ Laughter ]
Like, I literally wouldn't exist
if it weren't for foosball.
[ Light laughter ]
Which is sad.
But some of you wouldn't exist
if weren't for boxed wine,
so it's like yeah, whatever.
[ Laughter ]
Gets weirder --
Not only is my dad
a pro foosball player, he's also
a slam poetry champion.
[ Light laughter ]
And an international yo-yo man.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, my dad has the sex appeal
of a fanny pack.
[ Laughter ]
I'm lucky, though, 'cause most
parents are disappointed
if their kid
becomes a comedian.
But my circus-y parents are
like, "Wow, you did a show
and they paid you $12?
[ Laughter and applause ]
You're like a lawyer."
[ Laughter ]
Didn't pass the bar.
You guys just set
the bar very low.
[ Light laughter ]
We're a nerdy family.
Like, I have the deadly
peanut allergy, but some people
just think I'm on a diet
'cause last week I turned down
a peanut butter cookie
and the woman said,
"Oh, come on, live a little."
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "I'm actually trying
to live a lot."
[ Laughter ]
Not counting calories.
Just dodging death.
[ Laughter ]
I have so many allergies.
I'm allergic to latex.
Found that one out in a fun way.
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience ohs ]
My biggest fear is
a peanut butter
and condom sandwich.
[ Laughter ]
And it's scary because
I'm actually allergic
to most allergy medicines.
Yeah.
It's like Charles Darwin
just waving, "Bye, girl.
[ Laughter ]
You ain't making it."
[ Light laughter ]
I'm like the millennial mascot.
All millennials'
immune systems look like
the Charlie Brown
Christmas tree.
[ Light laughter ]
All fragile and exposed.
Older generations aren't scared
of things like gluten.
Old people are made of toast.
[ Laughter ]
My mom just told me that when
she was pregnant with me,
she only ate
instant mashed potatoes,
Skittles, and doughnuts.
[ Light laughter ]
I was like,
"Oh, that's why I'm broken."
[ Laughter ]
I got coffee with a friend
recently and she told me
that she's trying
to be a better person.
I was like, "Oh, that's nice.
What have you been doing?"
She goes, "Well,
I'm taking less selfies."
[ Laughter ]
Oh, take it easy,
Mother Theresa.
[ Light laughter ]
Save some of the Lord's work
for the rest of us.
[ Light laughter ]
Everyone says we're
so self-absorbed now
with our selfies, but I think
we were way worse before then,
'cause at one point,
we were all in school
and we all had
school picture day.
And then we ordered physical
copies of photos of ourselves,
and gave them to people.
[ Laughter ]
Like, narcissistic sociopaths.
[ Light laughter ]
Can you imagine doing
that now as an adult?
Just going up to a
coworker unprompted like --
[ Light laughter ]
"I signed it."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you guys so much.
[ Music plays ]
-Oh, my goodness.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Kelsey Cook, everybody!
For more on Kelsey,
visit kelseycook.com.